ok let's go with e for here efore and
then what is the game plan hmm more
Spanish game know we have the phila
doors defense okay what do you do one
response to this i need to come up with
a good setup ok the exchange variation
of the philidor mmm to take with the
night of the queen I think taking with
the night is best now with that exchange
my opponent gives up the center gives up
their central pawn the one that was on
one of those four is out of there and my
opponent is playing like they have
played this many a times i'm going to
take care and work on this imbalance so
there is play on the B file I wonder if
I could just do what I wonder if I could
no this is an interesting idea maybe h3g
for Bishop g2 i'm going to try that I
don't have a king side night right he's
out of there so there could be me maybe
some problems with the night coming out
in the Queen comin out in this direction
so h three stops the pivot on this
Square and is looking for this expansion
now with it i weakened f4 but i think
it's worth the investment to run with
this Bishop move or is it let's see what
my opponent does here I think Bishop a6
could be a bit annoying but it's not
without allowing this advanced here and
okay so I guess h6 is my opponent
looking to pivot about on this square i
do have this pawn around where i could
control it I don't know about the bishop
move because of a 5
then captures I want to be very cautious
by the way about giving up my light
square Bishop ok let's castle it's very
valuable because I have weakened my
Kings side I think without a doubt I
want to get this F pawn rolling however
maybe it's worth while they play my
bishop here and then tuck it back and
then do that actually that seems to slow
so i'm not going to do it let's go f
pawn gaining some space where does this
night go i think it's going to have to
rear out to d7 and c5 if this bishop
wants to see the game c5 is going to
have to be played but when it is my
night has this so that's a tough spot
for black I think all right you would
want to Bishop to see but it's not
without its drawback i get this Square
and this Bishop can't move and if it
can't move what is this real going to do
actually maybe rook e8 and Bishop FA is
the direction blacks be going in but
maybe they are now concerned about
something like h4 g5 and then I really
start to push the black pieces around if
I control f6 that could be a big problem
can it not ok Black is taking that move
into a coat Bishop and Queen are
controlling it I do not want to touch
this pawn no way and I want to give
these dark squares up so I think that
that was a good idea now what pawn push
maybe just Bishop here first let's do
that Bishop here I'm in a position to
meet there with this although i don't
know if i want to do that right away I
think Queen d2 rookie one these are hard
moves to argue with are they not Queen
d2 I am then fully developed by
definition fully developed means what it
means that the Brooks are in direct
contact
one another in order for my opponent to
be fully developed this needs to be
played and I'm winning upon correct I
have one two three four pieces on it and
there are only one two three in order
for this to being to be played
successfully or in other words without
loss of material there needs to be a
fourth defender because I have four
attackers one two three four one two
three they only have three defenders so
a quick head count is revealing that I'm
going to be able to win material this
nights not going to bother them anytime
soon this Bishop is unprotected in the
complications but there's not a way to
take advantage of it just winning
material even on time now how would you
recapture here Bishop Knight
well seeing how he is still very
important to me I'm gonna go with the
night and if the night is and i'm on the
bishop right now so if he isn't captured
right now i could now play c4 and if
he's chased away well then i can retreat
and the light square Bishop exchange
won't be happening so again bishop pair
open position okay so they're getting
out of the way of that being sneaky
there what about
this something real combo wait the
bishop could play here we support the
night I said I'd do that why don't why
don't I just do it if I took there'd be
there could be a queen capture and then
the Queen to be on my bishop so this is
a good spot for that guy what about what
do I do Queen see to
no I'm gonna go just a single snapper no
I want to get out of that pin my rook
wants to be on d1 that's the plan here
get my rook on d1 d1 and let's see how
black is going to be reacted to that I
think rook e8 is a very purposeful move
the rooks aren't doing anything the
black rooks are not yet doing anything
rook here and in response to that maybe
bishop here whoa was that a blunder I
think maybe c6 was men that's got to be
a blunder I can always back it up with
be four and now it actually comes with
tempo they wanted to take back
they want to take back the Queen move I
don't know I think maybe c6 was meant i
clicked on clicking on take back again
maybe it was the c5 move or something
there it is I think they have to cut it
back again you click on take back now if
they don't have the take-back ability
right now then we're just gonna have to
run with this position I guess it's not
working out there and it's actually my
move I have to go with it I guess I
didn't even realize it was my move right
there mom is ready just I have my clock
be spent right there so ok now let's
just trade I'm up two pawns these this
is a passed pawn now and I'll recapture
I guess with my queen just to cover this
dark diagonal and if there isn't an
exchange ok let's do this right now I'm
on the Queen actually let me do this
first and then get my queen to F to
support this pawn my night supported
with my bishop not my pond currently
because I'm opposite the rook oh wait
I'm dropping my H pond Oh Bishop takes
Knight I'm dropping the H Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes bishop Queen takes
h3 they're not listening to the stream
are they nope
oh they missed it they missed this trick
I'm have made on each seven the
in-between we've got them it's made on
each seven I just saw that right at the
last second right there good game let me
back up here and let's see how either
one of us could have improved there is a
tournament coming up real soon really
really soon let's see okay so I shoot
right for this imbalance the drawback
with it will be i guess my night not
being able to access d5 so easily and
the light squared Bishop deployment i
don't know if this is all correct it
seems interesting to invest this time to
get the bishop on g2 and have some sort
of Pawn avalanche maybe against that
King I think I'll play it again actually
if this did come up I like the position
that I got out of it so I think there
might be something else I don't know if
I'm should be going with the night move
right away maybe play the moves you know
you're going to make anyhow Bishop e7
queenside castle maybe reserve your
Knights options don't yet because maybe
in the meantime maybe if I know that
this structure is not compromised maybe
I then won't be going with h 3g for make
the moves like Bishop e7 the less
committal moves first castle is another
one and maybe in the meantime I will not
have been going with or I would not have
been going with the bishop on g2 the
fiend head o king bishop maybe that's an
adjustment and I think I stand better
hear this was a good awareness I think I
could very easily see many playing rook
e8 or queen d7 connecting the rooks but
I think there is something to be said
with h4 maybe with g5 as a continuation
I mean well it's definitely getting
critical because actually after h4 maybe
there's a CH 5 and the Knights looking
to outpost on g4 so I don't know if that
isn't a viable option to meet h4 with h5
then it is important to take into
account this advanced let's say rook e8
purposeful it's a half open file after
h4 and g5 I'm kicking the night away and
I'm taking away this f 6 square I've
control over it and I think that could
be very troublesome I kicked the night
away my queen would then have the g four
square Bishop here maybe there's already
like the rook coming to the H file and
stuff like that so good awareness there
by black to watch out for this advance
then the night move right away and this
is just losing a pond so something else
right rook here maybe Bishop back and
play it from there maybe rip to be ate
some quiet moves but small improvements
rookie 827 Rick v8 okay and also I mean
that this last point right here you
could get the material back instead of
the night move take the night I
recapture the bishop and then Queen
takes H I was going to be playing Queen
over here to defend but then there's
Queen check i have the more vulnerable
king I think the tables turn with Bishop
takes Knight black would actually be
better but we were both under time
constraints where we know okay